shocking as it may seem a Cameron Diaz
hasn't starred in a major motion picture
release since 2014 when she appeared in
the reboot of Annie it's hard to believe
that the woman who could pretty much act
in anything from mom comes to sci-fi
Mindbenders to big-budget action
vehicles and raunchy comedies has
virtually disappeared there are lots of
possible reasons why one of Hollywood's
eight girls has backed away from the
screen seen from typecasting to
lifestyle changes let's take a look at
all the reasons why Cameron Diaz has
gone from being one of Hollywood's
busiest actresses to barely-there
critical downsizing Diaz is critical
reception has been hit or miss over the
years at the turn of the millennium he
was wooing reviewers with her work in
films like this something about Mary
Being John Malkovich and Vanilla Sky but
her charms were off somewhere around the
middle of the decade because her film
started getting levelled by reviewers
after a 2005 drama d in her shoes
he has his most recent flicks have been
especially painful garnering some of the
worst marks of her entire career
these include gambit Annie and 2013's
accounts allure to godliness a bit cold
[Music]
I think truth has no temperature to our
credit though with Diaz can still turn a
mediocre movie into a box-office hit
when it counts
despite middling reviews bad teachers
surpass a coveted a hundred million
dollar mark in 2011 and she found
similar success with the 2014 release of
the other woman the problem is for every
hit she's had she's had just as many
flops the same year the other woman came
out to D s start of the underwhelming
sex tape which was ripped to shreds by
critics and earned disappointing returns
at the box office even the movie musical
annie' failed to catch him with
audiences or reviewers in other words
Diaz made her longer be bankable and
just a star power alone evolving
interests and Cameron Diaz made a
feature film debut in 1994 as the mask
she was just 22 years old and even then
her role choices were often interesting
she starred in a few dark comedies like
the Last Supper and head above water
before becoming a mainstream sensation
in my best friend's wedding even as she
fell into the cheesy romantic comedy
trap of the 90s she made sure to mix in
roles or some real meat in them when she
could nowadays that she seems to have
even less patience for paper-thin parts
than before even though those are the
ones I help to keep the lights on most
often as she told Collider of her
decision to star in the other woman
usually when it's a story about three
women all being involved with the same
man it ends in some eyeballs being
scratched down some weaves being
snatched off we decided that wasn't the
story we wanted to tell she said the
film was more about how the women
empowered one another by utilizing their
strengths and weaknesses to form a
friendship rather than turning on one
another as she notes though parts like
that are harder to come by and instead
what she's become known for her roles
are played to type in the last decade
Diaz has often played a variation of the
same character a career gal
inadvertently marries a party boy and
what happens in Vegas a single gal and
advertently gets tangled up in a
fugitive relationship with a spy and
night and day and the celebrity fitness
guru in a Hollywood relationship is
caught off guard by the demands of a
pregnancy and what to Expect When You're
Expecting even as bad teachers or Diaz
shift gears into a feisty ER mode it was
still just a derivative rom-com with a
bunch of f-bombs thrown in it's gotten
to a point where her career has become
the equivalent of writing a paper the
night before it's jus knowing you'll
probably get a C on it but accepting
that it will be good enough
things are about to change around here
perhaps des is holding out for something
substantial before she signs on for
another feature film or perhaps she's
considered the peak TV scene as our next
stop of course those close to us seem to
think there's something else going on
early retirement actress a longtime
friend of dr selma blair dropped in an
intentional bombshell about her the
sweetest thing co-stars career drawing a
chat with the Evening Standard when she
said I had lunch with Cameron the other
day we were reminiscing about the film I
would have liked to do a sequel but
Cameron's retired from acting she's like
I'm done
considering that wasn't exactly public
information the quote sent the
entertainment world into an immediate
tailspin and made everyone realize that
yes Diaz has been absent from the biz
for a long time
Blair did add that she didn't know if it
was a permanent decision saying I mean
he doesn't need to make any more films
she has a pretty great life I don't know
what it would take to bring her back
after the resulting commotion Blair took
to Twitter to clarify her comments
writing breaking news guys please I was
making a joke in an interview Cameron
Diaz is not retiring from anything and
for more breaking news I am now retiring
from being Cameron Diaz a spokesperson
but wait adir seemed to confirm her
friends comments during a March 2018
reunion with the sweetest things
co-stars
while bantering about family lives with
Blair and Christina Applegate Diaz said
that she's literally doing nothing and
actually retired was that an official
announcement considering the comedic
chops of all three of these seasoned
actresses they could very well have been
toying with our emotions
knowing that tabloids would flip and
they did was Diaz being serious or
sarcastic that tiny bit of torque left
us craving more info and movies from all
three of these women settle down Diaz
has previous high-profile relationships
of stars like Matt Dillon Justin
Timberlake and Alex Rodriguez made her a
regular feature of weekly tabloids but
all of that changed when she and Good
Charlotte guitarist Benji Madden became
an item the two dated for just a few
months before making it official and TS
has never sounded happier she gushed on
Instagram one of my favorite things
about being married is how much pride I
taking my husband he makes me proud
every day one day it might be how
generous and giving another how gentle
and thoughtful or when he is fiercely
protective of the people he loves and
cares about and every single day I am
serving
credibly proud of his integrity as a
human being considering it just been a
few years since you said she didn't even
believe in monogamy
it sounds like this romance took her by
surprise and swept her off her feet and
the screen new path
DSS absence from the big screen may have
been deliberate after all over the last
few years she's been busy carving out a
career for herself as a lifestyle author
in 2013 she co-wrote the body book which
quickly became a best-seller on the
heels of that success she released the
longevity book in 2016 which addresses
the science of Aging and explores our
own efforts to stay healthy as she gets
older as we get older there are phases
of life that we enter into what I
learned is that aging is really about
living in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Diaz revealed
something about some motivation for
writing that could be interpreted as an
increasing disdain with the vanity of
Hollywood as to whether she thought a
recommended anti-aging techniques would
be viewed through the lens of society's
diminishing value on Aging Diaz replied
I hope people will start to embrace it
more in that way but I think we do live
in a society where everywhere you look
every billboard every magazine every
advertisement that pops up on our
computer telling you where you're at in
age is scary and dangerous in other
words the DES is more focused on
personal wellness these days and she is
on conforming to studio's ideas of what
a body should look like that's obviously
a long very verjus revelation because in
2017 Diaz admitted she started to lose
touch with herself
the actress appeared on a panel
discussion at Gwyneth Paltrow's goop
Wellness Summit and revealed that being
part of the entertainment business took
a toll on her emotional well-being
saying I just went I can't really say
Who I am to myself which is a hard thing
to face up to I felt the need to make
myself whole the fame fatigue may have
prompted studios to award roles that may
have ordinarily gone her way to more
eager actresses or it could have been
exactly what it sounds like an extended
mental health sabbatical that she
certainly earned after two decades
spends maintaining a spot on the a-list
in either case Diaz is current Hollywood
hiatus seems to be mostly on her own
terms so whether or not she ever changes
her mind at least we'll know she's in
charge of her own future now thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to